Tom notch and T first I mean this was a
toning turning point in the whole phone
hacking saga wasn't it this was when it
really caught the public attention it
wasn't just a story that interested the
media because of this false hope that by
deleting Milly Dowler voicemails her
parents had thought she might be alive
it resulted in Rupert Murdock flying
over some would say this was what led to
the news of the world being closed so
how do you feel I'd like to say from the
outset that nobody who was at the news
of the world when it shut down would
make any excuse for hacking we were all
as appalled as everybody was a by the
hacking and and I'm not here to defend
hacking of mobile phones but this was
the one allegation that for me and I
know for a lot of other stuff because I
speak to them regularly the one
admission that made me feel sick you
know it made me think why am i working
for a company that would fund and pay
for the hacking of a mobile and deletion
of them it was more the deletion of the
messages during an active police
investigation adding further to the pain
of an already suffering family and I
mean I refuse to go into the office I
just felt so strongly about it I
actively looked for another job I was
actively looking another job and you
know I was absolutely appalled by it and
so now find out that actually that one
key crucial allegation wasn't wasn't
true it makes me you know it makes me
feel better and also we have to think
about the dollars in all this as well
because you know they they believe that
this deletion was done by the news of
the world they they were allowed I don't
know when the police or when the
Guardian knew about this new development
but they were allowed to go in front of
the Leveson inquiry potentially with
people knowing that actually the news of
the world weren't behind this and making
that that famous statement she's alive
and accusing the news of the world of
being a partner does it change anything
this well actually not is being now
falsely reported that somehow there's
been an exoneration of the news of the
world from deleting the message there's
still a current police investigation
going on it might well be that the
Guardian in their statement have got
this wrong it might well be that the
Guardian
running a story of the weekend has got
it wrong there is a current police
investigation all that the police were
saying was that they have some evidence
that shows that one individual Glenn
Mulcair did not receive written
instructions by email or or such until
after the false hope moment they haven't
said that nobody at the news of the
world was giving that information giving
those instructions to be the guy Mulcair
they haven't said that nobody at the
news of the world wasn't doing it and we
do know that there is an indication from
one of the people at least of news of
the world that he had Milly Dallas phone
number and he had Milly Dallas pin
number so he could quite easily have
done it so is your what you're saying is
that the police have not concluded that
the news of the world this is a damp
squib of the story I think the Guardian
has got this wrong to say that that the
news the world did not hack the phone
see it has not been determined but they
are also relying on police police
sources that that potentially got it
wrong in the first place
I'm just gonna bring in Nick Davies who
was one of the co-authors of the
original story about this Nick Davies I
mean this was crucial wasn't it in terms
of this story you had been doggedly
pursuing at phone-hacking for a long
time this was the turning point well it
was certainly a very important powerful
story bear in mind that six months
before we published a Milly Dowler story
Scotland Yard launched operating
operation we ting they had already
arrested the serving news editor and two
previous news editors they were off like
a runaway train crashing into the news
of the world separately in April two
months before this story news
international had thrown in its hand on
these very carful civil cases that were
working their way through the court and
you have to see what happened with the
Milly Dowler story in the context that
the news of the world were already
throwing in their hand and being
investigated by this powerful police
operation then when it comes to the
Dowler story itself the interesting
thing is that the new evidence which has
now been disclosed confirms that story
in almost all of its detail can you hear
me still yes we can still hear you named
carry on so it is now confer
by the new evidence just as we said at
the time that the news of the world
commissioned that investigator Glen Glen
Mulcair to get inside that missing girls
voicemail and he succeeded and news of
the world journalists listened to his
friends and found her friends and family
leaving heartfelt messages confirmed
confirmed investigator to get
confidential data from about the from a
confidential telephone database
confirmed that the sorry police knew
about this indeed nothing confirmed that
there were deletions confirmed that
there was a false hope moans all this
new evidence confirms all that one
element has shifted which is that there
is now confusion about who was
responsible with the particular
deletions that led to that false hope
moment the police are saying they have
evidence that Glen mal care the
investigator had not been investigated
by that state crucial isn't it because
the revulsion among the public was about
hacking of course but in particular
about the deletion of messages of Lily
Dallas phone and that false hope moment
and I wonder you know there has been the
suggestion that actually the news of the
world could have survived were it not
for that allegation yes but you're
you're giving a better account of the
story now than you did at the beginning
the the main point of this story here
I'll show you the headline you see it
Millie Dallas phone was hacked when the
Prime Minister stood up in the House of
Commons and said this is disgusting what
he said is they were hacking into the
victims of crime the victims of
terrorism this is disgusting when your
chairman Rupert Murdoch apologized he
apologized because they had hacked into
this little girl's voicemail and I agree
that the deletion was an important
element it did have an emotional impact
but it wasn't the whole story and if you
put it in the context that the police
were all over the news of the world was
six months by now and that they had
thrown in their hand on all those civil
actions it's delusional to try to
pretend that the new evidence on this
one element of one story would have
changed the outcome
I'm afraid that's mischief-making what
about being concerned about the coverage
that this new development has reached
that actually the Guardian had the
hacking story on its front page day
after day for weeks and weeks
this story and this correction was
buried somewhere deeper in the paper
okay so we had the Millie down a story
on our front page for one day which is
where it belonged as I've explained to
you 95 percent of that story has now
been confirmed by all the new evidence
we took the initiative we found this out
we put it in the newspaper on Saturday
we ran it prominently on our website it
was a page lead inside the paper it
would have been rather disproportionate
and weird to take new evidence that
confirms what we've been told and put it
all over the front page all over again
to give it a page but if you search for
this story on the internet now and you
look at the Guardian website and I'm
just looking at the page now the story
is still there with a small note at the
top saying see footnote 3 pages later
you finally get to this article was
updated on the 9th in the 11th of
December 2011 since this story was
published new evidence has led police to
conclude that the news of the world was
not responsible for the deletion of
voicemails from Millie Dallas mobile
phone that caused her parents to have
false hopes that she was alive what's
wrong with that well it's buried right
at the bottom of the story isn't it new
you're talking about the correction
that's on the story that was published
in July what we did was we wrote a whole
news story you wouldn't be talking to me
now if the Guardian hadn't published
this information that news story was
prominently displayed in Saturday's
paper prominently displayed on the
website from Friday night it's still
there on the website and the last time I
knocked half an hour ago that news story
still had its own headline on the media
pages
what's that two to three days after we
first published it but this is not a
newspaper hiding this is a newspaper
doing what it should do we ran a story
I'm sure that's not true you know the
story let's not hold on hold on hold on
it please this story was printed at
10:30 on Friday night while the whole
gyro problem was going on it was it was
written in the most convoluted confusing
way my father told me I can quote
haven't quote him on this he's a
guardian reader of 30 years you know
it's all about the phone hacking scandal
because of me and because of the
Guardian and he read that story and he
did not understand what point you were
making in that story Lee I'm sorry about
that Tom and I struggled to believe
there's someone with such incredible
experiences you an award-winning
journalist you and David Lee with 60
years journalist experience between you
would write an article that shoddily I
don't I don't understand that maybe you
clicks but I continue the only other
thing is that when you write a story
like that all the executives start
pecking at it and the lawyer has a
little go so the copy you write gets you
know fiddled with by the time that I did
I was clear as mad sorry
the story was as clear as mouth oh I
don't think that's there you have
certain editors notes on the top of it
explaining the exactly the point of
which which should have been the intro
but if that story wasn't clear
we wouldn't be now having this
discussion that people wouldn't be
tweeting about it they're doing that as
a result of what we've told them so it
is also a bit of people like me actually
getting on and saying hold on this was
completely unreported for several days
over the weekend because of the euro
crisis quite rightly some might say but
you know this was this has been a fight
back from people at news saying actually
hold on if we want a bit of parity to
report on on the apology the failure to
report on phone hacking at all by any
news international paper from 2009 till
2011 is a bigger problem the fact that
you tell you don't tell the truth so
that people can luck believe allied you
know if you want if the papers I'm a
reader of paper I don't publish a paper
I don't work for a paper if you get a
given news give the full news but don't
criticize each other for not giving the
news the whole truth is is that the
police have confirmed that they're still
investigating whether the news of the
world might have deleted those messages
that's a full stop
that's what affects the dandified
lightest and yes what the revulsion
might have been about but you also
hacked the phone of a dead murdered
school can I make out make an apology of
course it was any management who cause
newspaper rather than getting 300 people
who works there lots of their jobs who
have been nothing to do with any of this
and we are exactly but the management
took the view to close a newspaper
instead of giving jobs to good on this
journal this was the moment when people
started calling me scum
this was the moment my friends started
asking me did you hack a phone how would
you feel
Nick I don't even if he's still even
there but I mean how would you feel if a
store if something you had
nothing to do with because of that
tipping moment and it was that tipping
point it really was that was the moment
that the lesion yeah you know
interviewing an active investigation and
the pallbearers you know in all of this
or become porn sadly it's which is just
reported how would you feel if people
started asking you if you'd hacked
phones and you were calling you scum for
Tom the turning point if we can look the
power of this story is that the news of
the world hacked into the mobile phone
of an abducted girl and interfered with
police inquiries if you look at what we
wrote that's what the intro says we
actually know more than we did before
about the extent to which news of the
world activity obstructed the attempt to
find Milly Dowler if we tell the whole
story about what went on it actually
gets rather worse the story was about
hacking the girls voice mail and then if
you remember the next day the Daily
Telegraph produced a story about the
victims of seven seven also being hacked
and the cumulative effect of that got
the Prime Minister up on in the House of
Commons saying that it was disgusting
the deletions was a powerful factor but
it was not the main point of the story I
mean it's very unfair if you personally
are being blamed for hacking that other
people were doing but don't lose track
of the fact that the hacking was
happening it's been confirmed they did
hack this girl they've also hacked we
know and it's been said before the the
parents of the soem girls who had been
abducted and murdered it's the full scan
of the thing you can't get away from it
by saying that one element of this story
which was believed to be clear is now
not so clear Nick just put to you it's
not true
Nick I'm sorry to interrupt me can I
just put to you one of the tweets from
Haley Haley Farlow who used to run news
of the world PR and I'm sure you will
have encountered on numerous occasions
she says that the former news the world
staff demand guardian apology over false
claims paper deleted Millie Dallas
voicemails leading to closure and 300
job losses is it your understanding of
your belief then that actually the
deletion of the voicemails that part of
the story wouldn't have changed anything
that it was the hacking that really was
significant here and the end result
would have been the same exactly to
claim that it's the deletion element of
that story which made all the difference
is a grotesque distortion and there was
always the risk that if we came out with
the new evidence that mischief-makers
would get hold of it and try to make
more of it than should be made I have to
say on the whole Fleet Street has
behaved extremely well they've run
straight stories about it there's just a
little bit of mischief-making going on
and it should stop it's a much much
bigger scandal one element of one story
doesn't change the scandal I should say
Tom that I thought the decision to close
the news of the world was cruel and
wrong and the people who Haley speaks
for should not have done it it was an
entirely selfish and unnecessary
decision taking by the Murdock's
sacrificing other people's jobs to save
their own a very bad decision in the big
picture one element of one story is just
not as important as some people are
trying to pretend today Tom isn't it
right that it wasn't about the deletion
of the voicemails that it was about the
wider issue of hacking and the scale of
that I think from someone who was
involved in it in the Maelstrom if you
will you know right in the center of it
that's the thing people say to me it's
the deletion and you know and an own it
can say no our article wasn't about that
it was it was about hacking the boys
mode which is obviously completely
abhorrent and I'm not defending that I
need to make this very very clear I'm
not and nobody at the news of the world
would but it's the thing that people
that people say to me
Martinus you were involved in this for
many years until this happened it hadn't
got that public revulsion had it until
this moment the the public revulsion was
was to do with milli doubters phone be
it was previously there was this rogue
reporter lie that was being put out and
then he was saying but even if it wasn't
quite right this was just about
celebrities politicians sports people
and the fact that it was a victim of
crime Milly Dowler became an emblem for
it they were hacking ordinary people
MIDI Dallas seven seven victims the
sarin gas in a Josie Russell's family's
phone everyone there were some people
who were just absolutely they didn't
care it was a it was tragic as well on
all sorts of level people lost our
newspaper people lost their job because
of a small band of dishonest people who
were being affected and a management
decision taken by News International not
by the Guardian not by me not by the
Dowler's does this make any difference
to Bob and Sally Dowler well they would
like to be left you know they've had
this most awful year they've had to go
through the trial of someone who
murdered the daughter they've had to go
through everything and they're still
having to go through a debate and
question have been hacking their vote
daughter's phone it shouldn't have been
taking photos of them it shouldn't have
been hacking their home phone the news
the world had no right all the people in
the news of the world had no right to do
that yes Nick Davis which is that mark
is right to draw attention to the fact
that the police investigation is
continuing what they have established
that we disclosed is that they they
think they can say that Glen mal care
the investigator was not involved they
are not saying definitively that nobody
from the news of the world was involved
we haven't got to the bottom of the
barrel we don't understand how these
deletions occurred that led to the false
hope moment there have been various
theories and they've all collapsed so
it's much more gray than maybe people on
Twitter are presenting one element has
shifted that's all you can say sure I
would suggest Nick scraps maybe it may
be a lesson for your for your coverage
of this in the future perhaps what well
I think we've done pretty well with it
and that that story was accepted by when
we first published it in July all of the
parties involved even Glen mal care who
I spend a lot of time with Denmark Karen
he put out an apology through the
Guardian the day after we published that
story
he didn't dispute that the news of the
world had been involved in the deletions
he's right in the middle of it he
thought it was true he was very
surprised and relieved to discover a few
weeks ago that that I think was it's an
email probably that suggests he can't
have been involved that was news to him
that that's how extraordinary this new
evidence is he was in tears when he
heard that he couldn't believe it so if
you if you go back to the middle of July
what we were reporting was what was
accepted to be true by all of the
parties who were involved surrey police
started accepting that the news of the
world were responsible for the deletions
which caused the false hope in april
2002
do you see so this is not something the
Guardian were kind of inventing out of
thin air
all we did a lot of work on that story
before we published it all the parties
involved at that stage believed it was
true nobody denied it on or off the
record nobody tried to wobble any part
of this story now there's new evidence
that's coming up we can't quite make
sense of it
Glenn Mulcair appears to be in the clear
so who was responsible for those
deletions they happened no doubt about
it mrs. Fowler had her false hope moment
no doubt about it but who did it we just
don't know